foreign
[Music]
let's get started
so for those watching on YouTube I'm
streaming from Utah the Wilderness of
you time playing a Fisher random
tournament here
that starts tomorrow so the day of
recording is
2 A.M March 20th 2023
so I apologize for the low camera
quality and if the audio Peaks and stuff
you know apologies for that as well but
I don't see a good reason not to do a
speedrun game for here from here so
I'll do my very best to keep the quality
up
we are black against an 1875.
E4
all right let's go C5
go C5 Knight F3 Knight C6 and hopefully
we get another accelerated Dragon it has
been impossible to get Mainline
Sicilians in the speed it's amazing to
me that at this level we're still facing
the amount of Sidelines that we're
facing but it's eye-opening because it's
giving me a better understanding of what
I need to teach and what kinds of videos
I need to make when I get to a sort of
main opening videos which will be pretty
soon
B4 is the wing Gambit and the wing
Gambit is a I would call this a third
string Gambit let's say first string
openings are main lines like the open
Sicilian and the rosalimo the second
string Gambit would be the Smith Mora
the wind gamut is a one that has a very
dubious reputation and I would classify
it as a third string gamut because white
is worse with best play from black and
that's the distinction between an
opening like this and something like the
Smith Mora where black can equalize in
many different ways but black is
certainly not better in the main lines
so the idea of B4 is actually very
simple it's the same as most other
gambits you're trying to force the C
Pawn off of the C5 Square in order to be
able to occupy the center with uh the
d-pawn now B4 in this particular version
is a lot more rare than it is here this
is the delayed Wing gamut I think
because Knight takes before is an
additional possibility here I will admit
that I've never seen before played in
this exact position my guess would be
that in response to Knight takes before
white wants to play C3 Drive the Knight
back and then play D4 so it doesn't seem
to be sensible for us to take on B4 with
the Knight because that buys white a
Tempo that he can use to support the
center with C3 if that makes sense so
let's start by accepting the gamut with
a pawn I hope I don't get like crushed
with Theory here because I will admit
and I'm not even ashamed to admit this I
I knew the theory of the win game at a
long time ago in this version because I
was a nighter of player I don't know
anything about this particular version
of it I don't know if the Knight on C6
is a good thing or bad thing so we're
all on our own here and hopefully I'll
give you a window into how I try to
improvise when I know nothing about a
particular opening
D4 as expected first things first we
need to avoid getting blown off the
board and it seems to me that allowing
D5 here
is extremely unwise because the Knight
will have to go back to B8 so a big
mistake here would be to play night out
to F6 white would play D5 and then on
the next move E5 and the Knights will be
driven back to their initial spots
so
I think the obvious move here
is D5 well the uh the move that should
be on everyone's mind is D5 but
contesting the center before it's too
late and after the trade on D5 that
Queen cannot be attacked with the move
Knight C3 because our Pawn is
controlling that square I think I know
what our opponent is intending in
response to D5 e takes D5 Queen takes D5
I think it's this weird move c2c4
attacking the queen and yes I just
realized that I have played this guy
before it's too late to abort so we're
just gonna have to roll with it it I try
to play different people in the speeder
but it's fine I mean it's a game uh it's
actually a new set of challenges so I'm
more than happy to continue this game
I don't see an alternative to D5 I think
we should start with that move
and then we should cross the subsequent
bridge when we get there the only other
alternative that I see is the move D6 D6
is interesting because in response to D5
we can swing our Knight around to E5 and
if the knights are traded then we get a
pawn into the center and we kind of curb
we curb the advance of White's pawns I
actually think D6 might be a very good
way to avoid mainstream Theory so I will
admit that D5 is probably the best move
and black is probably better there and
we'll check it with the engine after the
game but I'd like to avoid Theory and so
let's make a somewhat more modest move
but one that our opponent is likely to
not know as well
if that makes sense so you're probably
looking at this in frowning and saying
well you're a GM you're supposed to be
principled but sometimes when you're
caught unawares and you can sense that
the position's incredibly sharp and your
opponent likely knows Theory making a
more modest move one that you sense
might be a little bit inferior uh it
could be a very good idea to force your
opponent to think with their own brain
but you have to be very careful you
don't want to make a bad flight out bad
move
so okay Knight B8 here is not completely
stupid okay as dumb as it looks here's
the thing our Pawn on D6 is doing a very
good job of stopping the progress of
White's epon right
it also should be pointed out that white
only has one piece developed so it's not
like we fall behind that much we don't
fall behind astronomically in
development with Knight to p8
but Knight to E5 still seems more
logical to me as a way of trying to get
another Pawn into the center
it's important to note that after the
trade Bishop B5 check runs into Bishop
D7 so we don't lose our Queen
what I'm expecting our opponent to do is
Knight takes C5 D takes C5 actually I'm
going to click on our game history
because I want to be reminded of how I
beat him
the first time I'm just going to look
through this game really quickly oh we
actually just played yeah our previous
game was was with this opponent so I'm
sure my YouTube editor will make a
smooth thumbnail out of that Bishop B2
as expected
now
this Pawn is a weakness and we certainly
shouldn't play F6 that would greatly
exacerbate our uh development
disadvantage it would prevent the knight
from coming out to F6 right now our top
priority well
I think we have two priorities the first
one is to develop our pieces at all
costs and we need to start now because
this is where
things can get out of control if we
don't start developing so can we make a
developing move that creates a counter
thread because I also don't just want to
give this Pawn away for free right
well there is a move which checks all
the boxes and that's the simple move
Knight F6 because it counter attacks
the E4 Pawn
and our opponent probably this is scary
because if this is still Theory then I
might just lose this out of the opening
but I'm going to call our opponent's
Bluff I don't see specifically what he
is intending in response to Knight takes
E4 so let's find out what grand scheme
our opponent has coped up here from a
developmental perspective this shouldn't
be that great for white because we both
have one piece developed so it's not
like you know white has a thousand
pieces out and we're getting attacked
Queen D4 is a scary looking move but I'm
not too scared of it
again Bishop B5 check always met with
Bishop to D7 so let's set that aside
what does this move do well it attacks
the Knight and it attacks the G7 Pawn
definitely not a pawn that we want to
lose because our whole King side
collapses so to me the move seems forced
I think we have to drop back to F6 here
just sort of making Force I mean Knight
D6 actually oh Knight D6 might have been
possible I didn't see that at all Bishop
takes G7 there might be this forking
move Knight out of five anyways Knight
F6 is totally fine C4 so our opponent is
trying to shove those spawns down our
throat
wow C4 well you might need to work
around those pawns because
we have lost the battle in the center I
don't want to go E6 here because that
merely exacerbates the issue it allows
D6 and then C5 and then we have a pawn
right in our Grill
so let's try to keep this Pawn on E7
that basically means one thing there's
only one way to develop her push-up such
that the pawn remains on E7 and that's
the fan keto with G6
now are we scared
of G6 Bishop takes Knight well then we
take with a pawn and an e-file opens but
white doesn't have a rook that he can
stick on E1
in that resulting position maybe C5
is scary
so it's iffy but I don't think it's bad
I think it's actually okay let's go G6
let's see what our opponent has has in
store for us here
it's slightly terrifying and I will
admit I'm scared I'm scared of this
position but I think we'll get out of it
and in retrospect I think D6 is a
serious mistake actually
I think I I under I simply
underestimated the the power of White's
Pawns in the center
and I had Sarah opponent has been
playing this incredibly like C4
is a is a Grand Master Level move and
probably we should have considered
taking on Passat but that would have let
the Knight come out of the gates and
from C3 the Knight had quick access to
B5 and C7 and remember we're not even
close to castling yet so we need every
Tempo that we can get here at least I've
gotten him to think so that's already a
great relief
yeah no odd Passat was possible I'm
sorry I should have mentioned that it
was possible I think some people take on
Passat by default because it's a cool
move okay this is a great relief
seeing this move is like okay let's go
Bishop G7 let's castle and when we
Castle we can start dealing with the
shenanigans that are happening in the
center another big advantage of our
position is a we're up a pawn let's not
forget that b the plot up before is
preventing the knight from coming out
that's a pretty big problem for white no
white can play Knight D2 but you should
agree that the Knight on D2 is a lot
less scary than it would be on C3 now
our opponent is track still trying to go
for our throat but this is becoming less
and less scary with every piece that we
are developing in G4 is music to my ears
I don't think it's scary at all because
white has half of his pieces on
developed white it's got his King in the
center I think we're going to be able to
turn the tables on White in terms of
who's attacking hope
now I think most people when you're
looking at this move
your instinct is probably to go H6
H6 doesn't really help because white
will just go H4 in fact it will merely
add kindling I was going to say Tinder
for the fire there is a wood use of the
word Tinder they will add kindling to
the fire because after white plays G5
right the H file is likely to open
and the H file opening is a huge problem
for us if we castle kingside and that's
the only way that we can Castle so I
propose that we ignore everything our
opponent is doing and just freaking
Castle anyway
G5 does it win a piece no because we
drop our Knight back to E8
simultaneously defending the bishop now
you might look at the still wait a
second
I've said many times over that in the
accelerated dragon and the grunfeld
you're not supposed to give up your dark
squared Bishop well there's two caveats
to that the first is when you give up
your Bishop for your opponent's dark
squared Bishop it's generally better
than giving up your Bishop let's say for
a knight because now white doesn't have
the machinery
to exploit the weak dark squares around
our King white lacks a dark squared
Bishop that otherwise would have been
terrorizing us from H6 let's say the
second thing is that there are more
important things in this position right
we're deflating the pressure and the
tldr is that there are more important
priorities we start by playing Knight F5
and finally pushing
this queen the queen has to move and
ultimately our Knight has access to the
D4 Square now what are we trying to
avoid in this position what is the
source of danger well there really is
none
there aren't a lot of sources of danger
here
because even if white plays H5 what is
white going to do next even if white
plays H6 the knight from F5 controls the
mating Square on G7 and 2 Tempe is an
eternity in this position so a lot
depends on where our opponent puts his
Queen
but long story short we're out of the
woods completely not literally because I
am in the woods right now as I'm
broadcasting the Stream
F4
so
what do we want to achieve in this
position well what was our goal when we
set out to get out of the the tizzy that
we found ourselves in at the opening
well it was ultimately to get rid of
White's control over the center it's
taken a 16 moves but I think we're
finally in a position where we can get
rid of the vestiges of White's
initiative in the center and the reason
is that I'm is because I'm not scared of
the move H5 which means that we have a
Tempo that we can spend on whatever it
is we want to spend it on and what I'd
like to spend it on is just getting rid
of White's central control because once
the Center opens White's King is caught
in the crossfire especially if we can
open the e-file so what move am I
constantly hinting at here well B5 is B5
is a great move I think B5 chips away at
the center from the base we can also
chip away at it from the tip which I
think is just more straightforward with
E6
why is it more straightforward because
it applies even more immediate pressure
on white center Bishop F3 okay
so now I think we have quite a menu of
good options we can play e takes D5 and
then throw in a check on E8 and then get
rid of that Bishop by bringing our own
Bishop out to E6
that looks like a simple and Incredibly
powerful continuation I'm not even going
to think twice about the other options
simple simple chess and I think some of
you might look at this and say well the
bishop on D5 is Super Active this is
where concrete thinking comes in because
I noticed that after I check on E8 our
Bishop comes out to E6 and the bishop on
D5 is totally destabilized it won't be
able to remain there
White's King is wide open this game is
not over and I was going to say CD is
the correct move by our opponent
so
first things first I'm going to throw in
this check because it's not going to
hurt okay throwing in this check driving
the king to a more vulnerable spot is
not gonna hurt
what do again what do we want to achieve
here well
I don't think that we should go for
checkmate I mean a move like Queen E7
might be very tempting but remember
white can bring the Knight out to D2 and
the E1 square is going to be controlled
I think we should complete our
development right it's important not to
forget that we still haven't developed
our Bishop and it'll be hard to play in
the long run without the services of our
Bishop and a rook so the move is quite
obvious when you put it in that way it's
not Bishop D7 because that's an awkward
move I want to do two things at once I
want to develop and I want to tackle the
last remaining annoyance in the position
which is this pesky pod on D5
so we combine these observations and we
play B6 we fee and keto the other Bishop
now am I not afraid of D6 here well D6
is one moveitis that's just a one move
threat and if you move the Rook to B8
big deal that pawn on D6 is surrounded
like a wood cabin from all sides
and we're just going to take it with our
queen or our Knight thank you uh
Wayne takes B4
I will admit in full disclosure I did
wonder that pawn
not see that I was hanging
it's uh pretty late at night
but I don't think it changes anything
I don't think it changes all that much
that pawn was not very important
anywhere right who cares who cares about
Pawns
now we're just gonna continue as though
nothing is the matter just gonna play
Bishop B7
in all seriousness that was an important
Pawn that pawn was doing exactly one
thing but it was doing a very important
thing it was preventing wife from
playing Knight C3 so apologies that
might have been the biggest mistake I've
made so far in the speedrun
there is a silver lining to us
blundering the pawn which is that we now
have another Tempo that we can use to
accumulate the pressure and when I say
accumulate the pressure what I normally
mean is like bringing pieces into the
game and literally making contact with
our opponent's pieces and I see a good
way to do that which is a rook to C8
bringing our last remaining piece into
the game
and putting pressure on the night and
you'll hear this term a lot in chess
commentary putting pressure putting
pressure that translation of that is
just like contact between your piece and
your opponent's piece but notice I'm not
saying you're threatening your opponents
because a lot of people confuse these
two concepts when you're threatening a
piece you're going to capture it if
you're mate if you're putting pressure
on it
you're just making contacts with it 94
is a great move
by our opponent
well let me think about this
some very complicated tactics here
okay
soccer Queen it's kind of interesting
actually
base six qg2 I have to calculate some
stuff
some detail there that I missed
oh
oh my gosh I see a beautiful line
okay because we're low on time I'm just
gonna make these moves and then I'm
gonna explain them properly after the
game we're gonna start with a check on
A6 we're setting up what are we setting
up we're setting up the move Rook C4
obviously Knight F6 Jack is a huge
threat
and you might say well why shouldn't we
just move our King the problem is if we
move our King into the corner the White
Queen is going to check it along the
diagonal see we're paying the price for
giving up our dark squared Bishop that's
the price that you pay and then our King
is going to be driven back to G8 where
it will be forked and the fork might not
even be the biggest problem biggest
problem is going to be the lack of uh
protection around the king we're just
gonna get mated so now we play Rook C4
but all of this hinges on a detail
that's incredibly easy to miss and these
are the Tactical details that you have
to see if you want to be 18 1900 at
2000. what detail am I talking about who
can tell me the crucial line which
allows Rook C4 to work
work in quotation marks it's it's still
not clean but I think it'll give us a
big attack
yeah so if white throws in
the intermediate check on F6 we have
Queen takes F6
simultaneously we are attacking White's
Queen and we're attacking the rook in
the corner which is actually very
important because white has the counter
Desperado Queen takes rook and in
response to that if we were to Simply
take the Queen White would take our
Queen and we would be down in exchange
right because white has eliminated a
rook and we've only taken the Knight on
F6
yeah so white probably should have
played King G2 because then okay the
line gets very complicated we'll talk
about that after the game
what I missed from a distance is not
this move although I also missed this
move this move I think is bad I think I
think our opponent is starting to slip
at this point we need to abandon
material considerations and we need to
go directly for checkmate
what is surrounding the white king what
is the protection of the white people
it's really the two minor pieces the two
minor pieces are what's preventing our
Knight and our Rooks and our Queen from
just infiltrating the wide open King
side and the King side is wide open
because these pawns are no longer
affording the king even the shred of
protection so what do we do we make a
move basically intuitively even though
it is a sacrifice technically it's a
sacrifice I don't really think of it as
a sacrifice we just eliminate the Knight
on our own terms and now we eliminate
the bishop on our own terms why is it a
sacrifice well because presumably our
opponent is going to take our Bishop and
if he survives that resulting position
then he deserves to win this game
so Queen takes A6 is what I'm expecting
and then we have to think very carefully
about how we want to conduct our attack
so the obvious move to me is Queen takes
Pawn because that sort of involves the
queen and it sets up the threat of Rook
E4 to G4 check now we could also play
Rook G4 checks straight away
if the king moves to the H file then we
can take on H4 with check and then take
on G5 and we win the issue is that the
king will run the other way King F1 then
we can take on D5 and we need to
understand whether the inclusion of this
additional check actually benefits us I
think the answer is no but let me think
about this for a second there are some
actually very very complex complex lines
here
so we could also by the way play Knight
takes H4 that's another possibility
and this one I would not discount Knight
takes H4
but then the king runs the other way
King F1
I don't like that
I think we should probably go like this
Rook H3 there's always Rook G4
or we could throw in the check it's V
see I I have no idea what the right
answer is this is
this is a very high degree of difficulty
kind of situation
I'm gonna throw in the check I am going
to throw the check and I there's one
consideration that prevailed I'll show
you guys this line after the game it's a
super cool line
assuming that our opponent doesn't
blunder into it okay now we take
now we take
we're hitting the Rook
okay we're hitting the Rook
and what else are we doing well we have
a lot of these sort of tactical threats
like there you might notice like 93
check and if the F pawn moves away
there's a check on F3 so your your
spidey sense should be tingling but
there's a very important observation I
should make in this position which is
that you shouldn't think of this as okay
either our attack succeeds or we lose
the game only down a tiny bit of
material and this is honestly very
disappointing it's disappointing that
our opponent just collapses like this
it's common for that to happen at this
level
okay our opponent just blunder screen G2
check which is pretty anticlimactic
yeah we won the rook and we win the game
easily because all white has
Queen CA check and that's a pathetic
that's a pathetic check because we just
move our King up to G7
and that's game over because we're also
controlling the C3 as if we needed that
we're also controlling the C3 Square so
check King up Queen C3 check we're
controlling it and even if we weren't
controlling it we could block that check
on D4 which is what we would have had to
do
a couple of moves earlier if our
opponent had actually tried to defend
this position properly
yeah that Peak will definitely be edited
out of the the final YouTube video
yeah those watching on YouTube my mic
apparently just went nuts and knocked
everyone's ears out
but you won't hear that
because of
the magical editing work okay our
opponent is like
this is what I would call pinching a
dinosaur where we're like checkmating on
the king side our opponent is busy like
gobbling up grains of rice on the queen
side this is at this point we could just
focus our attention on the king
and essentially any check is going to be
Checkmate but there is an art there is
an art to checkmating the king in these
types of positions and I will say that a
lot of people struggle
perhaps you will identify yourself among
this number a lot of people struggle
with this final stage of actually
checkmating the king so what I just said
about any check working that actually is
not really true in this position there
are two obvious checks there is Knight
F5 to D4 there's Rook G4 to E4
what you want to avoid is a situation
where your pieces are basically
stumbling over each other and that
situation occurs after a knight D4 check
because if you look at the position
after King to D2 what you want to do
there is deliver a check on D4 with the
rook in order to set up some sort of a
ladder made construction but you can't
do that because your knight is in the
way so you might say well 94 check King
T2 let's go Knight F3 check but what's
the drawback of that move well then your
queen is blocked from the third rank so
you don't want that either so it's
important to actually start with a
rookie four check drive the king to the
D file deliver another check on D4 with
the Rook the Knight is actually
extraneous the Knight isn't really a
necessary attacking piece in this
particular version of events
so now we check the King again and
notice how the rook and the queen are
combining here if the king moves to C2
Queen D3 is going to be Checkmate in a
couple of moves if the king dips back to
E1 then we've got a lot of options we
can win The Rook with Queen H1 we can
win The Rook with Queen C3 and we'll
probably do one of those things and I'm
sure there's forced mate there as well
and this is why earlier today I had a
lesson with botes and I recommended a
chessable course that's called a that's
a 1121 mates I'll link it in the
description to the YouTube video and
it's like 600 Maiden twos 500 made in
threes and like 400 metaphors it's like
the easiest way
to develop your ability to find
checkmates quickly because this is one
of those things that literally can only
be attained through practice there is no
logical process to detecting mating
patterns you just gotta freaking do it
so what's the fastest mate here
well there's made in three
Queen D2 Rook B4 and queen C3 or the
simpler one is actually just to give a
check with a rook
then to deliver
um actually no I I went for the longer
mate by accident but it's fine it
doesn't matter as long as you see the
maid it isn't who's who's counting right
Rook C4
and let's deliver the latter made
yeah so unfortunately that was a very
anti-climactic attack this could have
been very juicy and I will admit I
missed quite a few moves in this game
I'll chalk up partially to the hour and
to the fact that I was at a five hour
flight today but I think this made the
game more interesting and it made it
more realistic and the point of the
speedrun is not for me to show how
perfect I am it's actually the opposite
right you to expose all the
imperfections let's start by analyzing
the opening
because this is quite important and
this is something you're likely to face
like not often but once in a while and
you should know how to play against it
also somebody in the chat said that the
wing gamut is the reason that they don't
play the Sicilian so we definitely want
to tackle this uh properly so let me
pull up chess space
and let's fire up the Beast let's fire
up stockfish
and let's see what stockfish has has to
tell us
as well as the reference about about the
wing Gambit so it appears to me
I've just fired up stockfish I'm going
to let it sit for a moment
in terms of what people actually do
ctex before is by far more popular
which is probably why we should go for
Knight takes before
huh
yeah I actually think stockfish tend to
prefer Knight takes before at least in
the early going of its calculation
so what's happening after night takes
before white plays C3 that's the only
logical move
we drop our Knight back to C6 and white
plays D4
so this position occurs
and notice the difference between this
position and like this position which is
a subtle difference right here the plot
is shifted to before and there are
pluses and minuses associated with that
so let's consider this other version
how does the engine propose to play here
well it proposes to play in a way that
nobody plays the most popular move here
is actually D5
which apparently allows white to
equalize the computer line is cdcd and
actually this kind of weird looking move
E6
okay so who can tell me why our
intuition is against the movie six E6
looks like it I don't want to say loses
but it looks like it runs right into a
super nasty move turns out that this
super nasty move loses on the spot for
white so you're gonna have a badass way
to meet the wing Gambit
you're gonna have a badass way to meet
the wing Gambit
my computer is thinking is making sounds
folks
because I'm running stockfish yeah D5
D5
is very annoying because our Knight is
driven away and this is exactly what I
said we had to avoid it's actually
winning for black who can spot and if
you're watching on YouTube you should
pause what is Black's winning move in
this position
yeah I I ran stockfish on my chess base
so that's why it was
that's why it was laboring
yeah Queen F6 Queen F6 wins for black
because the Rook of the corner is
literally trapped and this is a category
of traps that you should be intimately
familiar with they occur across all
openings like the most famous
instantiation is actually probably the
Queen's Gambit and the Queen's cabin
accepted there's a very famous line
that's been known since the 1600s where
white goes E3 black supports the pawn of
B5 white chips away at it black defends
white trades and white traps The Rook
with Queen F3
in general something that's not talked
about a lot is how the rook in the
corner is an incredibly vulnerable piece
and when the when the Center opens up
you should always be aware of ideas that
end up hitting the rook in the corner
because sometimes you just don't have
the Machinery to deal with that so we
compare this to this position which is
basically identical white has to take
the Knight and this Pawn looks very
scary But whichever way it takes the
bishop just recaptures and most
importantly most importantly white has
no way to trap the queen in the corner
because I'm sure you've seen lines where
you know white has a bunch of pieces
developed and her Queen gets trapped
with like Bishop B2 right so let's say
white plays like this black plays like
this
a white White's top engine move is Queen
B3
now black is supposed to develop The
Rook to C8
hitting the bishop if Bishop B2 then the
Knight is lost so white has to burn a
Tempo playing a move like Bishop to D2
now the engine on chess.com likes Knight
to E7 which I think is totally
reasonable ah and the idea is very
simple you're actually heading for D4
notice how you're keeping your queen on
A1 now finally white has a threat here
and the reason why I didn't have this
before Bishop C3 seems to trap the queen
but black is a beautiful tactic that
defends against it who can spot it
there's a lot of tactics in this opening
Bishop B4 so you're counterpinning the
bishop
and you might say well then White's
gonna take the bishop but if you
calculate all the way to the end you
have a check on C1
and you pick up the rook in the corner
so very nice Zen madman got it so this
tactic is the reason why you bring the
Knight to C6 to support the B4 square
but the secondary reason is to play this
move Knight C4 and finally white is
basically forced to take the queen is
evacuated and black is up a full
exchange and a pawn and white has
nothing to show for it
so where how did we get here
so the important moves to remember are
e65 and queen F6 this is basically all
you have to remember the other moves are
pretty intuitive
um if C takes B7 well the engine likes
the idea of throwing in a check
uh which is you could do that you can
also just take on B7 and you're
completely winning okay Bishop B5 you
just develop your knight and defend
against checkmate
and White's probably just gonna go like
this oh no but now the Knight is saying
so now this is just a disaster this is
just a disaster
um if white plays E5 here then you play
Knight takes C5
and the problem is that you still are
aiming at the rook and you're
threatening well you're threatening just
to take White's Knight and then to take
the rook and if white like fiancatos
notice that no squares along this
diagonal are defended so you're just
gonna end up losing the bishop and then
the Rook
if white plays Queen D4 you're gonna end
up losing your queen
probably the most resilient is 94 but
now we apply pressure on the Knight with
Bishop C5 White's gonna defend and
according to the engine you should
develop your pieces because you're
already up a pawn and you've got just
like amazing pieces of amazing pieces in
the center and it's plus six here this
position is only a pawn down for white
but it's plus six oh and there's a
reason why there's a winning move in
this position let's see who can find it
black to play and win a ton of material
in this position
yeah minus six minus eight
big numbers big numbers here
96 yeah Knight C6
yeah it's up to minus 7.25 yeah this is
this is enough uh for us to convert
Queen F2
Queen B2
and white is just massacred everywhere
no pieces developed takes apparently the
best of is actually Bishop takes F2 the
idea being to drive the king up to D2 so
you could take with check if the kick
goes the other way you have a check here
and you pick up the bishop and then pick
up everything else there's other winning
moves but this is the simplest so what
we have figured out
and I don't think there are any other
moves in this position white could try
this oh this is important this move is
very clever because if you grab the
Knight then white develops the bishop
with Tempo more importantly white
connects the rook and the Queen and then
why recapture C6 and
you're gonna be up a pawn but black is a
much better move Bishop B4 wins the game
here because now if white takes then you
take with a bishop and you win The Rook
if white plays Bishop D2 again you take
the bishop sorry you take the Knight and
you hit the rook in the corner so you
actually emerge up a piece
um the salt giant asks a very
Illuminating question in the line that
we just considered so let me play
through that again E5 Knight takes E5
um what were we looking at 94 Bishop C5
Bishop E3 I think no Bishop B2
here white took is it the same thing if
we put the other Knight on C7 basically
yes yes you can put the other Knight on
C7 the only reason we stepped back with
this Knight it was in order to increase
the number of attackers on the night on
D4 so it's a little bit better
so hopefully this makes sense to
everybody that's not the end of the
analysis because of course White's best
move is to avoid D5 but the good news
folks is that D5 is the most popular
move in the database and Christopher
Hugh the Grand Master in a rapid game
against pragnananda she actually played
D5 here and he lost the game after Queen
F6
so Christopher you played the move Queen
B3 here prognanada took and this wasn't
like a Blitz game this was a rapid game
Christopher played E5 which is also how
a lot of people play this
and hear the best move
is hard to find it's A5 and prognanada
played it well you're trying to go A4
and dislodge the queen from B3 so that
you could like get your own Queen out
eventually
Christopher played Bishop D3
prognananda played A4
driving the queen back
which apparently is inaccurate according
to the engine Bishop to B4 check is an
improvement
let's say white steps up
and now black is an amazing idea C5 no
way
now this looks like it loses the queen
self-evidently but again black has one
of those moves that counter-attacks
white screen and by forcing the queen
away from B3 black carves out an Escape
Route for his own Queen if Queen C4 then
the bishop is lost if the queen goes the
other way you take the pawn and you run
away through me through now at your
level I don't think anybody's gonna play
all these moves with white these are
like super high level defensive moves
but you'll still know how to deal with
them if white covers with a bishop then
you just take the bishop and again you
play A4 at the point of moving the queen
away from C2 is so that you can occupy
sorry B3 you can occupy the B file with
your rook and the point of that is to
create an escape Square for your queen
queen B2 is coming next actually here
you take the Rook so why can't even
can't even move the Knight
it's hard to see and the A5 here is a
very hard move to come up with if you
don't know anything about the position
yeah A5 just going down the side of the
board but hopefully you understand the
logic it's a two idea move the first is
to create an anchor point for the bishop
the second is to drive the pawn down to
force the Queen off of B3 to allow your
Rook to get to B8 to enable the queen
ultimately to escape through B2
okay so that's enough on D5 if white
plays this more conventionally and plays
Knight to C3 which is I think the only
other move that you're gonna face
then apparently let me turn on stockfish
again
okay we can use the chess.com engine but
that's not ideal I will turn on
stockfish so my computer will
start worrying for a little bit longer
okay so apparently the best move here is
Bishop B4 Bishop D2 Knight F6 which
makes sense you just develop your
freaking pieces you just develop your
pieces
and if white plays Bishop to D3 which is
the top computer if white plays D5 here
then black wins by taking the Knight and
taking the pawn lots of tactics here
related to undefended Pieces because
white moved the pawn away from B2 Bishop
G7 there is check
and now just a rook G8 counter-attacking
the bishop black is winning
so that's not satisfactory and if white
plays Bishop to D3
then black plays DC I like D6 because
that keeps the options open in the
center D6 it also stops E5
and white has insufficient compensation
for the pawn it's about 0.5 so the
weight gamut is really not that bad it's
not that bad I I didn't realize that it
was better than its reputation is there
was a there's a game here that continued
Rook B1
and according to the engine the best
move is to support the bishop with the
move A5 and then you basically want to
play E5 and contest the center black is
better no question that black is better
here
white is insufficient compensation Queen
C2 you can strike at the center with E5
and you
and you can probably move the Knight
back to ba no problem because the center
is now closed your Bishop's going to
come out your Knight's gonna re redeploy
through A6 to C5
and uh I think black is doing great here
so the novelty by the way is A5 there's
still a game in the database here black
played Bishop A5
but I like A5 a lot more because it
cements the bishop of the pawn
um note that
okay here if white plays E5
then it it creates a a big weakness I
mean these two light squares are really
weak so black could actually take and go
Knight D5 but the engine likes Knight to
E4 Which is less intuitive because the
Knight isn't defended here but in this
position you have this check on A5 and
it's stronger because after 92 black is
pressuring this square with more pieces
now this move is very strong
and Knight to C3 wow and at the end of
the day you're going to win the D4 Pawn
so many cool lines in the wing gamut
here that we're exploring but hopefully
you're getting a hang of how to play
this the tldr is that the best way to
play this at least according to this
like very amateurish analysis is to take
with a knight to drop back and then to
not play the move D5 here that's the key
temptation to avoid and by the way the
reason you don't play D5 here is because
it's like a scandi where your queen gets
tossed around and white has the
possibility of playing D5
Mantra Frost says I don't understand so
if you could break down your lack of
understanding into a specific question
like which point did I lose you then
I'll be able to repeat it or phrase
something in another way
um so as long as you remember that
you'll remember to play E6 and you'll
remember that Queen to F6 is the key
idea in response to D5 if white plays
Knight C3 then we bring our Bishop out
with Tempo we bring our Knight out and
we actually put the d-pawn on D6 rather
than D5 which allows a kind of French
Advanced structure that we're trying to
avoid because we could get Greek gifted
you understand why
why you don't play D5 here it's because
this is a structure you're trying to
avoid and the reason you're trying to
avoid it is it's very hard to Castle in
these types of positions because there's
always going to be a Greek gift
sacrifice
so what how does it help for us to play
D6 well we're preventing E5 how are we
preventing E5 because here we can take
the pawn
why can we take the pawn because if
white takes back he loses the bishop on
D3 yeah white recaptures the Knight but
in this particular position he loses the
Knight on C3 but even if he didn't we
could just recapture on F6 and be
winning
okay and you're trying to permanently
prevent white from playing E5 by
ourselves playing E5 Marie Lopez style
later in the game
there are other moves other than Knight
C3 like for example white could play
here immediately but your style of play
is going to be the same I think a check
here would be a good idea maybe white
can play like this
but I I think you could just play Knight
F6 anyway and ultimately if white
doesn't play Knight C3 well you just
keep playing D6 you know eventually
White's gonna have to develop the Knight
and you certainly don't mind a trade of
dark squared Bishops not at all
this check you just go back to C6 and
we're chilling
okay
so anyways that's enough in the opening
our strategy was to take and here
definitely
what's funny is the engine doesn't think
black is better after D5 I was right my
intuition
told me to stay the heck away from this
position
this position already seems very bad to
me practically because if you move the
queen you run into D5 if you take on
passant you get a scandi style position
where this Knight on C6 is an incredibly
vulnerable piece by the way what other
opening do we see something very similar
happening
and we have this opening a lot in the
speedrun what comparison can we draw in
fact we get almost exactly the same
types of sequences in that opening
who can
think what I'm talking about we had a
game just like this
it's a sicilian it's a type of it's an
elephant in the alopin with D5
if black misplays it then we get almost
identical sequences now the difference
is that white doesn't sack upon but for
example if black just nonchalantly
develops his Knights white plays Knight
C3 we had a game like this and once the
queen moves it's literally like an
identical position the Knight is pushed
away the pawn on D5 like Lords over
Black's position here black loses the
Knight
so you can see how similar this would be
in the event that we would move the
quantity it's exactly the same the same
stuff it's almost the same position
it's even worse for black because the
Knight isn't even on F6
now the improving factors that we can
play no not this move we can play Queen
A5
and the difference is that white lacks
the B2 Pawn versus the allopin so we can
buy ourselves a Tempo but after Bishop
D2 who wants to play this position I
mean your Queen's vulnerable D5 is a
threat the engine gives E6 and says
black is fine but D5 is still possible
and look at White's development
Advantage here I mean Knight takes D5 is
a threat it's a disaster
so stay the heck away from lines like
these that's why I played D6 but
probably it was a better idea to play E6
anyway I simply did not know this idea
Queen F6 slipped my mind completely so
we decided to push the other Center pawn
and after D5 I think black is already
quite a bit worse at least practically
speaking according to the engine this
position is still approximately equal
but I think it's incredibly hard to play
any questions up to this point and
please don't feel shy like anything that
we analyzed hopefully I made
some degree of sense
when showing these variations
okay yeah D5 is the classic advice right
meet all the gambits with D5 but no
that's wrong
uh Knight takes before is best as we
just kind of analyzed okay sorry I had
to refresh because I got disconnected
okay so 95 takes takes Bishop B2 Knight
F6 this all makes sense Bishop takes E5
is correct Knight takes C4 and queen D4
our opponent plays amazing in this
stretch I didn't really sequence I mean
I saw Queen D4 and at this point it
dawned on me that like we're worse like
we need to get our pieces out are we
gonna get steamrolled
so
we have a couple questions
this opening is called the wing gamut or
the delayed
Wing gamut the classic Wing gamut is B4
in this position we will not analyze
this today because we have enough to
look at in the Deferred Wing Gambit
um Mason asks oh yes so Mason asks in
the position where
so in the line that we were analyzing
boom boom boom boom boom boom I think
Mason is referring to the position
if white plays here black plays here
white plays here black plays here
castles D6 so there was a question
doesn't uh White win the Knight with D5
no count the Defenders and the attackers
black has two Defenders on that square
white is only one attacker so you can
just take twice and if white delivers
the check on e4 then the bishop can come
out and simultaneously guard the net or
or we could block it with a knight but
it's a better idea to do this while
developing
okay
um
so on we go to the game continuation
let's go back to this moment Queen D4
and F6 and so we decided to play G6
again E6 runs into D6 and I don't want
to analyze this any further because
every single person should understand
why this is a problem because we can't
we can't get anything out and White's
gonna support the pawn with C5
okay so we decided to play G6
here I was terrified of the move C5 this
is the move that I think was White's
biggest chance to get a big advantage
and I think after C5 we are in serious
trouble we're in serious trouble the
issue that our our opponent should play
too slowly just too slowly our opponent
let us develop our pieces and then
played this very bad move which just
allowed us to bring all of our pieces
out at no cost it conver in fact our
opponent made weaknesses in his own
territory so this was very
counterproductive
why is C5 a good move well what does C5
achieve well it achieves a couple of
things obviously it opens up a pathway
for the light squared Bishop to jump
into B5 but mainly just advancing the
pawns can be incredibly dangerous
because Black's control over the center
is extremely limited so I would have
played here
now white delivers a check and there is
a detail that I missed from a distance
which is that if we play the move that
we were relying on for the whole game
which is Bishop D7 who can tell me what
the flaw is of this move in this
particular version and it's an easy move
you should see this quickly
C6 yeah C6
C6 BCTC and you lose your Bishop because
if you move your Bishop you lose your
queen to a discover check
and you might say ah but I can block no
but The Bishop's guarding that square so
either you lose your queen to pawn to
xd8 or Bishop takes D7 choose your pick
so of course if we reach this position
we'd have to like castle and give up a
full bishop and we can resign
so that what does that mean that means
black has to move the king
a little this is disgusting now the
engine gives the move Bishop back to C4
which makes perfect sense to me you have
to solidify the D5 Pawn if white falls
asleep Queen takes D5 is possible
and you might say ah but I can remove
the defender no because I take the queen
and at the end of the day The Rook is
actually trapped not that that matters
so white maintains the tension with
Bishop C4 it's plus 1.3
but you can understand why because black
can barely move okay we can develop our
Bishop but it's just an incredible
position for white Rook D1 white at some
point will play the move A3 why would
white play A3 in order to free up the
Knight so that the Knight can join
Society uh and it wants to join Society
because ultimately White's gonna
threaten the move like D6 but hopefully
when you look at this position it it
makes intuitive sense that even though
black is technically up upon white is
like borderline winning here
if white played this perfectly yeah
white would win that's what I'm saying a
clear Advantage basically means with
perfect play it is winning most of the
time for the side of the clear advantage
okay
so C5 that was the key Bishop takes F6
would have been a very bad move because
this would have conceded control of all
of the dark squares
and most importantly C5 now would run
into what move who can spot the flaw in
taking on F6 first and then playing C5
and you should like understand anytime
there's a capture you have to understand
what squares are now accessible to your
pieces you have to keep updating your
perception of the board yeah if you do
that you spot Queen E7 check immediately
because previously that square was
inaccessible was occupied by Pawn the
moment the pawn moves away you're like
oh I now have a check on E7 but what
does this check do what wins the C5 pod
white can take this one but after Rook
G8 why doesn't huge trouble because
Bishop to G7 is totally Unstoppable it's
Unstoppable
castles Bishop G7 goodbye
The Rook is lost
so in any case C5 that was the only way
for white to maintain a big Advantage
instead Bishop E2 is a major step in the
wrong direction I still think white is
better according to the engine if white
simply castles and plays the move A3
liberating the Knight white is still
better ba Knight takes A3 the knights
coming in look at White's control over
the center so really the culprit was G4
this was I would even go so far as to
say almost the decisive mistake
um and it's a sensible move from a
conceptual standpoint
it's it's normal to drive the pawn down
to G5 like this the problem is that it
makes too many weaknesses and it's way
too steep of a price to pay
uh to
abandon your development abandon your
Center get rid of your own incredibly
strong dark Square bishop and all of
this for what right so I don't I don't
want to over explain this I think it's
clear why G4 is a huge mistake and once
this happens okay white can play C5 now
congrats at this point it's totally
empty and black has plenty of ways to
work around White Center
even the move 96 here is possible this
just shows you how big of a difference
the last couple moves have made
can't take because your queen is lost
guess what you're going to lose G5
you're going to lose C5 your position's
collapsing
apparently the move B5 is very strong
here on Passat Bishop B7 just a way of
fiend ghettoing the bishop with tempo
and blacks pieces storeman Rook C8 Etc
B5 is a nasty move
bang bang oops sorry no Queen takes D5
look at B5 B5 deflection but also a
developing move
tanqueto on steroids anyways our
opponent continues his campaign we get
our Knight into the center we blast open
the center
we blast open the center now there was a
very interesting positional alternative
here and I really feel bad that I
dismissed it because I think I was a
little bit too stubborn I think e takes
D5
maintains the decisive Amendment who can
spot a more positional peace placement
oriented approach to trying to win this
position what is the alternative to e
takes D5 and it's not like rookie 8 is
also possible but I'm talking about a
fundamentally different way of treating
this position
no Queen D6 is too much too much Russian
school boy why would you trade queen
look at White's King you still
ultimately ultimately you want to get to
White's King
okay so Queen A5
is one move by this you're attracted by
the threat of B3 but you're allowing
white to escape
so nobody has said it yet actually this
is really interesting oh IPS 10 got it
E5
and I said well didn't you just say that
you're trying to open up isn't the whole
point of this position to open up the
center now you're closing it down
so as I was saying
just because something has a clear minus
doesn't mean you have to bury it the
queen has to move what is the idea V5
it's to stick the Knight on this
incredible incredible Square on D4 once
this Knight reaches D4 the game is over
Bishop moves away we can even chip away
at the king side with F6 and we still
can open up the position but look at the
domination that you are exerting on
White's position and
as a follow-up you can still chip away
at this Pawn chain it's just you can't
do it with E6 but I already pointed out
the other way in which we can do it we
can do it from the other direction with
the move B5 we can fly through a
different airport if white plays A3 we
could just stick B5 right in White's
Grill and the game is over White's
losing these Pawns and the Queen's
coming in it's just it's so one-sided
here
so I somehow forgot that after we play
E5 we'll still be able to shatter White
Center with a well-timed B7 B5 I got
very fixated on the prospect of opening
up the e-file and I think this made our
task a little bit more difficult and B6
was obviously a an oversight I still
think it might be the best move but
somewhere around here I might have
messed up a little bit
so Bishop B7
yes sweet drop says is it also a good
Outpost because it is hard to trade the
Black Knight with the White Knight and
the answer is yes
um the Knight on D4 is what in Russian
we call an eternal night it's like
almost impossible for white to even get
to the night now according to the engine
after E5 the best move is Queen to H2
and white has to find the ridiculously
computer-ish Knight to D2 the Knight is
so good that the engine is with the
engine is willing to sacrifice an entire
exchange for it and it's the evaluation
here is -3 so black is still completely
winning
um but which human would ever do that
right
um
which which human would ever do that
um a human would play Bishop E4 and lose
after Bishop F5 because you can't take
two to the fork now in reality a human
wouldn't play Queen H2 a human move here
is either a queen D2 or something like
Queen C1 and in both cases the eval is
like minus five because of this move B5
does that make sense to everyone I know
I broke off there for a bit
uh but but hopefully the logic makes
sense this is a great lesson for me I
got fixated on one particular idea and I
didn't give the other ideas a chance
anyways I blundered before and then I
underestimated 94 and it is a miracle
that we have Bishop A6 and Rook C4
because otherwise white is much better
I'm checking with the engine and Bishop
A6 Rook C4 is -2
but um if we don't have this then why
does borderline winning because well you
can't stop Knight F6 otherwise now I
have an interesting question for you
guys
let's say that you didn't have Bishop A6
and Rook C4 what would be the Lesser
evil how would you
deal with the threat of Knight F6
because there is a move that gives black
very good practical chances due to the
power of Black's minor pieces and the
weakness of White's King
yeah it's Rook takes Knight so in the
absence of Bishop A6 I would absolutely
sacrifice The Exchange on e4 this is
infinitely better than allowing a check
on F6 I think a lot of people might play
a move like this okay but once you allow
a check on F6 suddenly remember these
things they're called Pawns white plays
H5 we're checkmated so what was once a
ghost town becomes a booming City and
Black's King is caught in the crossfire
the game is over now we should probably
go here now the engine gives Queen B2
winning for black uh winning for white
because look at this x-ray we can defend
the queen The Rook but not forever it's
going to be lost and black can't even
get an exchange for it because of uh
sorry rookie one too many attackers on
the rook and if you play have six black
takes with white it takes a check and
then wins The Rook
so such is the power of a knight on an
outpost and so a good lesson is that
even if we didn't have Bishop A6 I think
we would get a lot of chances in a
position like this we could play Rook C5
and it's anybody's game because the
Knight is so powerful
anyways we did have Bishop A6 Rook C4
and what this hinges on is the fact that
if white drops back then we get two
pieces for a rook and we're completely
winning
of course I think our opponent makes
probably the decisive mistake with Queen
A3 because in this resulting position
and I actually played the correct move
and I stand corrected
there was no defense here it's -10 of
course a more resilient defense in this
position would have been what our
opponent played Rook H3 blundering this
and we can stop here how would you guys
defend here with white what could you
propose here and then we'll go back for
a second and consider them more
resilient
so there's a couple of options here
there's Rook G1
what else can you guys name
Queen E2 blunders the Roku checkmate
Rook H3 is what our opponent played at
bonus Queen G2 there are other moves
here that should be considered
consider the prospect of
counter-attacking yeah you can throw in
a couple of checks
in order to bring the queen closer to
the defense this is what I'd like to
start with here I calculated Knight T4
and this position is actually not that
clear unless you see the Checkmate from
a distance I had to spot this diagonal
check on B5
and of course once you see it it's
obviously made in two but at first I
didn't see it and I thought oh it takes
takes four no because the Knight is
pinned
so you have to see Queen B5
so that's rolled out Rook G1 is the
other resilient move and here
the best move is incredibly hard to find
I'll give you guys a chance if you're
watching on YouTube this is a great
chance for you to build up your
attacking skill the best move the move
that wins most cleanly is in my opinion
it's it's easy to see this move but it's
hard to appreciate why it's so good
so a lot of you are spotting Knight E3
unfortunately this is inaccurate
if you take them this is Checkmate but
wife can run toward the center King E2
and suddenly black is in some trouble
because you don't have any the Knight is
helpless on E3 when the Knight is at
Close Quarters with the King it's
actually on its worst possible spot the
correct move is Rook G4 to C4
there are two main reasons you're
preventing Queen C8 so there's a
prophylactic component but the main
thing is that you're preparing this
devastating check on D3 you're cutting
off the Queen's connection to D3 white
has to go here and now you reveal a
third a third concept behind Rook C4
which is to set up a discover check
against the white king
by doing so you're forcing White's King
in one of two directions if it goes into
the center
this is obviously Checkmate check check
and mate this is easy
okay if the King goes the other way
then Checkmate is waiting for the king
via Rook G4 check
and then you can for example bring the
queen in and bring the queen in a little
bit further and this is just gonna be
wow you can staircase your way to
Checkmate and ultimately you're gonna
make the king I'm showing this fast
because there's a thousand ways to win
this position you could take on H4 or
Rook H2 I'm just going down the main
computer line F3 of course doesn't
actually win The Rook because Rook H4 is
check
so lastly why you could try to block
with a queen but obviously there's a
move everybody should see this is a
discover check against the queen and now
throw in another check using the pin
notice the roll of the Knight which is
guarding the E3 square and the queen is
now lost
okay so this would have been
uh we would have been forced to find
this if our opponent had come up with a
more resilient Rook you want
um after Rook C4 the game is over any
questions about this particular sequence
that I just showed
I would say well what are what are the
lessons that we can distract well Rook
C4 is a hard move to find
one thing you should notice is that when
you're attacking
don't get the wrong impression from
solving studies that every attacking
move is glamorous in fact most attacking
moves are business like moves like Rook
C4 that open up new squares for your
pieces
so just appreciating the role of These
Quiet Moves can really help you find
them in your own games it's elegant it's
this is chess beauty of a different kind
um no I it would possibly work if the
Knight was in another square but F5 is
an ideal location for the night because
it's controlling so many of the white
King's Escape squares and it's also
acting as an anchor in case you need to
take on H4 when the white king is on H3
the knights defending that square as
well
okay it also is stopping the queen check
and that of course speaks to the role of
prophylaxis when you're attacking which
is a whole separate topic which we'll
address later the last thing I want to
address in this game is to talk briefly
about White's more resilient move which
would have been Queen to B1
and after Queen to be won I would have
done the thing oh
oh
my God this is the perfect way to end
this analysis the engine I admit I
didn't find this my idea was to sack The
Exchange and go Knight D4 and black is
winning because the king is doing the
engine spots a ridiculous combination
watch this you go Knight to D4
now what seems to be the flaw inherent
in playing Knight D4 immediately who can
spot like what what is it that
why did we sack The Exchange in the
first place
well it's because we don't want to allow
Knight F6 right
and the problem is if you move your king
this allows white to move their Bishop
H5 is coming next and it's a complicated
position can anybody spot the hidden
idea here and this
the next move is just the tip of the
iceberg
what are you supposed to do here you
sacked the queen on F6 yes
now you take the bishop
now the king can't go to F1 because it
gets checkmated easily
but the King goes up to G2 and now the
creme de la this is the coup de gras
this next move is freaking awesome who
sees it
Rook G4 Roxy 424 are you sacked the
Knight
this ladies and gentlemen is what we
call Checkmate
look at that look at that made in
construction he sacked the knight in the
end
um no there's no way I would see that
even in a classical game probably not
I would have a chance if you gave me 30
minutes and you told me there was a
tactic
yeah Elementary my dear Watson Bishop A6
to E2 x-ray defending the rook and if
the king dashes the other way then
Bishop C8
so the bishop goes either to E2 or to ca
back to its initial Square setting up
Unstoppable threat of Checkmate in fact
there is a way to stop it which is to
play Rook H1 to C1
now a huge mistake would be this because
white takes the bishop so here you
calmly move the bishop away and white
has to give up the queen in order to
prevent Checkmate and black is up a full
night and the king is basically mated
so watch what the bishop does it goes
from Asics
so it's just the whole Arc of the attack
is awesome it goes from B7 to A6 it
supports the Rook which goes to C4 which
then goes to G4 and the Bishop from A6
goes either back to C8 or to E2 with
mate just the way that pieces work
together in chess is so ridiculous
incredible
um absolutely incredible anyways not to
like make too big of a deal of what what
is a pretty normal combination but it's
crazy that it actually could have
occurred in this game I would have
played rookie for though there's no way
I would have seen that
all right
um and on that note folks I think it's a
good time for us to call it a day just
to remind you our opponent played Queen
A3 that allowed us to sack The Exchange
in a much more convincing version
because well here the king is wide open
and it's getting attacked from all sides
and of course we're working G4 to C4 is
uh the key attacking move we would have
had to see in the event of Rook G1
by the way Rook H2 there's the simple
move Queen to F3 with unstoppable
threats of Knight E3 and Knight G3 Etc
any questions folks any questions about
any part of this game of course we're
not analyzing the rest of the game here
because it's very very simple
okay uh Rook G4 was best my move was
best if you remember during the game I
was a little bit undecided about whether
to take first or to play Rook T4 I
correctly decided to throw in this check
and the main reason why is that the Rook
is now hanging
and the reason I decided to do this
truly is because of this line where we
have this check on B5 so driving the
king to F1 was a great thing because of
this additional mating pattern that
takes the sting out of Queen C8 Queen C3
if we would have taken here first Vanna
White would have been able to check and
check and compared to the position with
the King on F1 apparently white has this
move and White's still alive because now
if you give the check white can block
with a rook remember that the Knight is
pinned so there's never going to be a
fork I need to and it's -3 but the game
very much Rook H4 King F1 Rook H1 Rook
G1 the white still holds on here
and technique is required all right guys
I'm gonna have to wake up for breakfast
at 10 30. so I'm going to call it a day
here I think for a log cabin speedrun
game this was good apologies for the
tech problems I think it'll be edited
out in the YouTube video
but it's 4 am I need to go to bed
urgently
and I want to thank everybody who joined
me on this cabin stream
hope you guys have a great start to your
week and I we'll head to bed I think the
internet held up very nicely given Where
We Are
foreign
[Music]